[ Applause ]
>> Alan Alda: All around the
country today, distinguished men
and women are looking
at graduates like you
from the heights
of our achievements
and spraying advice at you.
It's an indignity you have to
suffer before they lift the lash
and release you into the wild.
In settings like this today,
you're going to hear all
over the country many
of the same themes:
be true to yourself, follow your
passion, you are the future,
don't make a mess of the
world the way we did.
I know these words because I've
said many of them myself often
and they're good ideas.
The only thing is today
they're a little vague, I think,
and every time I'm tempted
to make a speech like that.
I wish instead I could just
give you a few good tips
on how just to get through life.
Like the admiral last year who
gave one of these speeches,
his advice was so
concrete, so simple.
He said, "If you want
to change to world,
make your bed every day."
Isn't that wonderful?
I love that.
It's so-- I mean,
it's utter simplicity.
I mean, if you could start off
a day with a little discipline
like that, there's no telling
what you can accomplish
when the hard stuff
comes your way.
The problem is I can't really
give you that advice myself
because I don't make
my bed every day.
I do, I unscramble the covers
and I pull them up to the pillow
so it looks sort of neat, but
I don't make it, you know,
all so tight that you
can bounce a quarter
on it the way the admiral does.
I'm looking at your faces.
You're thinking why are
they having this guy
up here talk about
making his bed.
There's actually a reason
for why I'm saying this.
I think it's important
as you leave here today,
if you haven't already done
it, to start paying attention
to how your own particular
brain works.
You know, the admiral likes
a hard-discipline approach,
the experience of being tough.
He likes that and I'm sure a lot
of you benefit from that, too.
But I'm a little more flexible.
I pull the covers up just
enough so the next time I look
at them it'll be a
little gift myself
and I'll get a little jolt
of some happiness hormones
when I look at it and
that's good for me.
That's the way I like it.
The point is that
there's no good or bad way
to start the day, I don't think.
But I think you can learn to get
the most out of your particular,
your own brain, if you pay
attention to how it works.
I used to push my
brain, you know,
sort of like the way a jockey
would whip a horse trying
to make it run faster
than it can run,
but now I'm more tolerant
of the way my brain works.
I'm easier on it.
I get it pointed in a
certain direction and it works
in the background in its own
time and when it's ready to come
up with the goods,
it lets me know.
But the thing is, it takes time.
You know, I bring this
up because if I'm going
to pass anything on to you
today it has to be real to me.
For instance, my grandson
Scott is graduating today
and that's very real.
[ Applause ]
That's real to me
and so is the fact
that he'll be entering my field.
He's going to be facing
a lot of uncertainty.
But, you know, uncertainty
is not always a bad thing.
In fact, I kind of
welcome uncertainty.
I think instead of resisting
it, you can surf uncertainty.
You'll keep your
balance, stay agile,
expect the unexpected bumps.
That's harder to do when
uncertainty comes at you
like a tsunami, but it's a
good principle to live by.
The thing is, it's not just
Scott who's going to be going
out facing uncertainty
in his chosen field,
every one of you here today
is going to face uncertainty.
It's going to hit you.
You'll face it no
matter what you do
and sometimes it'll make you
rethink what you're doing.
And here's an interesting
thing, uncertainty usually comes
from the outside, but sometimes
it can come from your own heart.
If you suddenly are
up against a situation
where you remember what
your own principles are,
what your values are, sometimes
the choice can be difficult.
I'll give you an example.
My wife just wrote a book
about people who were brought
up in the Bronx and
I'm-- At the Bronx.
All right.
Good. Very good.
Excellent.
Read the book.
You'll love it.
So I met one of the people in
the book that she interviewed
and he told me such an
interesting powerful story
about this thing I was
just talking about,
about knowing your values
and coming up against them,
coming up against
something in your own heart.
He came from a working class
family and his father had lived
through the depression and his
father told him constantly,
be a plumber, people will
always need plumbing.
But this was a very smart kid
and he went to medical school
and he was so smart that as a
young man he invented a device
that would save lives and a
medical company offered hundreds
of millions of dollars for
the patent to the device.
The only thing was
they were going--
For some reason they were going
to hold it back from putting it
on the market for a whole year
before they started selling it.
Now that meant that he
could either release it
to the public right away
and start saving lives
or he could take the hundreds
of millions and wait a year.
And his father, who had
lived through the depression
and kept telling
him be a plumber,
his father said don't do
it, don't take the money.
He said think of all the
people, the mothers and children
who will die during that year
while this company is waiting
to put it on the market,
put it out there now.
And then every night
when he went to bed,
the father would say to him,
when you wake up tomorrow
and you look in the mirror to
shave, don't look at yourself,
don't think about your own
image, think about those mothers
and children who are going to
die if you wait for a year.
So what do think?
Did he take the money or did
he put it out on the market?
He had to make a decision.
It was a very tough decision.
And sometimes you have to make
really tough ones and they come
at you unexpectedly like that,
but you can certainly
surf uncertainty better,
you can find your balance better
if you know how to respond
to your own principles.
So I'll tell you, I'll
tell you what he did.
He didn't take the
money and decades later
when he told me the story,
he was really happy about it
because he did what
he thought was right
and it makes him feel
good to know that.
But here's the thing,
that was many years ago.
In those days we had time
to think things through.
We had time to consider
these things.
You don't have that
luxury so much anymore.
All of the sudden now,
things are going really fast.
Let me give you an example
of how fast things are going.
I love this example.
A few years ago the Internet
was flooded with copies
of a graduation speech that
Kurt Vonnegut had given at MIT.
It spread across the country.
It spread all over the
Internet, all over the world,
and it did that in
just a few hours.
That's how fast it was.
It was quoted everywhere.
And I'd like to read
some of it to you.
I love it because it gives
very simple advice, clear-cut,
everyday, how to live
your life advice.
He said, "Here's a few words
for the graduating class.
Wear sunscreen.
If I could offer you only
one tip for the future,
sunscreen would be it.
The long-term of benefits,
the long-term benefits
of sunscreen have been proven
by scientist, whereas the rest
of my advice has no
basis more reliable
than my own meandering thoughts.
I will dispense this advice now.
Enjoy the power and
beauty of your youth.
Oh, never mind.
You will not understand
the power and beauty
of your youth until
they've faded.
But trust me, in 20 years,
you'll look back at photos
of yourself and recall in a way
you can't grasp now how much
possibility lay before you and
how fabulous you really looked.
You are not as fat
as you imagine.
Sing. Don't be reckless
with other people's hearts.
Don't put up with people
who are reckless with yours.
Floss. Remember compliments
you receive.
Forget the insults.
If you succeed in doing
this, show me how.
Stretch. Get plenty of calcium.
Be kind to your knees.
You'll miss them
when they're gone.
Get to know your parents.
You never know when
they'll be gone for good.
Be nice to your siblings.
They're your best link to your
past and the people most likely
to stick with you in the future.
Don't expect anyone
else to support you.
Maybe you have a trust fund,
maybe you'll have a wealthy
spouse, but you never know
when either one might run out.
Be careful whose advice you buy.
Advice is a form of nostalgia.
Dispensing it is a way
of fishing the past
from the disposal,
wiping it off,
painting over the ugly
parts, and recycling it
for more than it's worth.
But trust me on the sunscreen."
Now the thing about
this charming piece
by Kurt Vonnegut is that it
wasn't written by Kurt Vonnegut.
It was written by a
newspaper columnist
in Chicago called Mary Schmich.
Some unknown person
had posted it
on the Internet saying it
was written by Kurt Vonnegut
and it spread all
around the world in hours
with his name attached to it.
Schmich said it went to
Italy and France, to Israel
and Brazil, to places I
didn't know had electricity.
And she said even
Mr. Vonnegut's wife,
the photographer Jill Krementz,
received and emailed it
to several friends and then
asked her husband why didn't you
tell me you spoke at MIT.
And he said, "Because I didn't."
Somebody said it was the
most widely distributed piece
of email in the history
of the Internet.
But after only a few hours
of bouncing around the world,
it was identified as a
hoax and, in a flash,
the Internet was
flooded with retractions.
At the end of one
extraordinary day, vast numbers
of people had accepted and
then rejected a worldwide hoax.
And that's what makes this
Internet event a great image
for the age we live in now.
There were probably just as
many lies going around now
as there ever were, but
these days they're traveling
at the speed of light and
with the help of an engine
for repetition that works
on a scale unheard
of in human history.
The lies stick.
People are still sending
around that talk saying it
was written by Kurt Vonnegut.
All right.
So big deal, you
may be thinking.
You may be thinking it's just a
few jokes about youth and beauty
and trivial things,
but think about it.
It could be selling
you anything.
It could be a cult religion that
could separate you from friends
and family or a quack medicine
that could leave you paralyzed
or bogus political information
that could decide an election.
Being able to know what's true
and what's a lie is a lot harder
to do now, harder
than ever before.
And so now, more than
ever, you need the wisdom
of a trusted partner or
a friend or a mentor,
somebody who can remind
you of what counts.
Now, more than ever, I think,
you need to know who you are
and what you believe in.
And who you are is a
tough one because most
of us have many people inside
us, but in your finer moments,
you aspire to things
that make sense.
Even while you're enjoying
a momentary distraction,
you know that down the
road something's going
to come along that's going
to require skill, ability
and you're going to
know you can't wing it.
So you're going to
be prepared for it.
You're going to know that one
of the deepest pleasures comes
from knowing how to do
something that's hard well
and you'll be prepared.
You'll take the time that
it takes to learn it.
We have a challenge
about time now.
So let yourself be all
the you's that you are,
but don't let them
crowd out the smart one.
And as for what you believe
in, values are really not
so much what you
say as what you do.
The more you bring those
two things into line,
the easier it'll be to
get where you're going.
You know, you may say you want
to go to Chicago, but it's going
to be hard to get there
if you keep buying
tickets to Las Vegas.
I think we don't realize
how important time is.
When we couldn't communicate
at the speed of light,
we didn't think about it that
much, but things do take time,
like the time it takes for
your brain to work on a problem
and chemical reactions
take time.
Mourning a loss takes time.
In fact, all the transitions
of our life take time.
Getting your brain or your
body in shape takes more
than a weekend, no matter what
they tell you in the brochure.
It takes time for a
species to adapt to changes
in the environment that we
cause, which makes us one
of the most dangerous
species that's ever lived.
We can make changes in
the environment so rapid
that nature doesn't have time to
replenish species that can live
in that changed environment.
And I don't want to kid you
into thinking I've got
this all worked out,
that I know how to do it.
I'm still working on it myself,
but this is what I aspire to.
So this is real to me and
I'm passing it on to you.
So as you make the transition
from this page in your life
to the next chapter, I wish all
of you what I wish for Scott.
I wish you health, happiness,
resilience, love, laughter,
patience, cash, strength,
plenty of time,
and a friendly relationship
with your own brain.
And if all else fails, floss
and wear your sunscreen.
Thank you and good luck.